Ladies, college campuses are no longer a place to go and find a husband.
And you can thank feminism for that.
Let me explain. On the bright side,
we have a lot of women that are now getting their college education.
But statistics are showing that women greatly outnumber men in college.
Affirmative action and all that BS.
But when you put yourself in an environment
where you are not a rare commodity any longer,
meaning the ratio is one man to every 10 women.
The men can go around and have whoever they want.
They can act a fool and do whatever they want
because they are pretty much guaranteed sex.
Especially with our modern day culture.
So you're looking for a relationship.
I would absolutely advise to not try to find one at college.
And the second point to this is
I personally
do not think that women should be dating men of their same age.
Don't make lateral moves. You want to date up.
I was engaged at the age of 20
and what was I thinking
when that man's brain was not fully developed till we were 24?
If you want a serious relationship,
you wanna get married young,
you wanna start kids young,
or at least
find a man while you're at your peak fertility and attractiveness.
Then you wanna be putting yourself in environments
where you have successful men
that are older than you. And you're not gonna find that at a frat party.
Honey, this right here is why less and less women are finding husbands,
especially in college. Then they get their career,
then they work their way up through boss babe culture.
Then all of a sudden, you're 35
and wondering why all these men are going after young 24 year olds.